the friendly nature of russian relations
greece is one of russia's principal
partners in europe
this year the greek nation celebrated
the important date of 200 years
since the start of the fight for
national liberation
and we can say confidently that this is
our
shared celebration uh russia made a
contribution
to the liberation of greece to its the
creation of its nation for the statehood
and our friendship
and support to one another is time
tested and this is
a foundation the foundation
of at the present day
despite the troubles
healthcare situation our relations
continue to develop
it's hard to overestimate the importance
of our
dialogue on the highest level credential
level
today we have reviewed the agreements
reached
by the prime minister of recent
president of russia
as well as the decision discussed
during the meeting of the head of the
government of russia mr
schuster and the prime minister of
greece on the 24th of march in athens
as well as during their telephone
conversation that took place on the 5th
of may we have discussed of course
the ways to combat the spread of the
covet
of the no coronavirus
and have agreed to
prevent the spread of uh harmful
effects of recovery 19 pandemic
our two nations are interested in
expanding ties
in promoting trade and investment in the
energy sphere
in other spheres
restoring uh tourism
the intergovernmental commission and the
planned recession of the
government commission russia and greece
should take place as soon as possible
we have discussed the legal and
contractual framework
of our relations we have agreed to
expedite the preparation of
many documents so that during the
upcoming
contacts and meetings we'll be able to
sign them
we have been developing quite
successfully
cultural and humanitarian ties
and this year under the patronage
of our two leaders we are holding the
russian greek year of history comprising
over 120 events
in russia and greece the carrying out
of this celebration of this events
will help develop
develop cooperation and friendship
between two countries
we have touched upon international
issues and agreed to cooperate in
multiple international organizations
primarily the u.n
uh
current relations between russia and the
eu
and we have noted that fortunately these
relations
are not in their prime right now um
it wasn't russia who initiated the
sanctions spiral
that came from brussels we are ready
for constructive dialogue with brussels
but it has to be
based on uh mutual respect
respect for our rights not based on
unilateral
legitimate demands we have also covered
the situation
in balkans in the eastern mediterranean
and libya in syria
in transportation
you believe russia believes that all
contacts
conflicts that continue to rage on in
this
these areas can only be resolved through
diplomatic means based on
the national law
confrontation our colleagues have shared
their assessment of the recent meeting
on the cyprus
peace process in the
russia is committed to resolving the
cyprus
dispute according to the on the basis of
the u.n resolution
we are happy with this dialogue and we
believe that
our greek uh
colleagues would also like to develop
friendly
ties with russia going forward and i
would like to
thank mr dendiaz for his visit
and i know that we'll visit
i would like to him to visit napa and
other parts of
russia which have ties with greece
there's a diaspora
diaspora there which is an important
country
makes an important contribution to the
relations between russia and greece
thank you
few months i'll take this visit to
i am grateful and for your hospitality
and uh flexi everything
is connected with the greek history from
the ancient times until now
and uh there is a prominent
bricklayer here i will meet with
samantha and jacob
tomorrow and you know that this year we
celebrated 200
years with the greek revolution and we
would like to
uh emphasize that we're thankful to
russia
for its contribution to the uh for to
the liberation
of our uh homeland and our independence
the tide between our two countries are
historic
and um there are many levels in our
relations
and we hope that we will hold a lot of
events
during the history of russia and
here we talked about our bilateral
relations today in deepening
them based on the
talks that took place in athens
when prime ministers of greece
and russia met in greece
uh attended celebration of the
anniversary of the independence of our
country
as far as the economy goes there are
many different
there may be different projects and
prospects in our bilateral relations and
the trade between our countries of
course
uh decreased in the latest years so we
discussed russian investments in areas
like tourism and real estate
and uh renewable energy and i
underline under emphasize the importance
of tourism which
unites our countries
we also said that
our country is ready to
welcome vaccinated russian tourists or
if they can provide a negative test for
enormous tests
and in order for them
to travel we
we also covered in detail the
development
of the regional agenda especially our
relations with turkey and of course the
cyprus peace process
uh greece wants to develop the positive
dialogue
and greece wants to be open and honest
with turkey
and uh we want to be guided by
international law
we are also satisfied with the fact that
russia
has publicly stated its support of uh
territorial integrity in the country
and also its territorial waters
we also appreciate that russia
follows the results of the university
council and remains committed to that
but we are concerned that turkey is
again trying
to defend the ottoman empire legacy
and it's trying to become the leader of
all muslims on the planet discuss the
middle east issues especially russia's
contribution to
the stability in this region russia
is the permanent member of the u.n
security council
between russia and the eu because
these relations have significantly
deteriorated
in recent years in the situation that
uh it concerns us because
that these relations are very important
and
partnership between the us and russia
was signed 27 years ago
and
friendship relationship between russia
and the eu because we don't like what
we're seeing right now
we want to bring the ties and the
relations and the partnership to the
top level that it used to be at
an integral part of uh the european
security architecture
it plays a very important role in uh
solving regional and global uh
issues
we want to normalize relations
between uh
between the eu and russia and greece as
part of the eu
because we have european obligations and
we will continue
to put our efforts into stability
stabilizing this relation
these relationships
[Music]
the question was for mr lavrov from the
greek television station
we're talking about the um eastern
mediterranean
and the cyprus peace process turkey
wants to change the basis of the peace
process
and they are pushing towards this
two-state solution
but in libya uh turkey insists
that on its presence there and the armed
forces
turkish armed forces are in libya what
does russia think about that
in my speech that russia
would like to resolve all diplomatic
issues like that through
the use of
and
on many occasions we have voiced our
position
over the past years
efforts to resolve the cyprus issues
have
intensified we have seen the position
that the
guarantee of
security for cyprus would be to transfer
this
issue to direct oversight
by the five permanent members of the u.n
security council and
if the sides involved would like that to
happen and they support this idea
we would also support that so so that we
could
carry out everything according to the un
security council resolutions
my question is for the greek foreign
minister
you mentioned that one of the documents
one of the necessary uh documents that
greece will accept
is what is going to be the vaccination
certificate and you accept
sputnik the russian vaccine is an
acceptable vaccine but
you're not buying russian vaccine
waiting for it to be registered in the
eu do you know when
that's going to happen because some are
saying that maybe in the end of june the
russian vaccine will be
registered in europe or do you plan to
manufacture it and
that way to work towards resuming the
same amount of air traffic between the
two countries
thank you very much for your question
it's two questions are connected but
they're actually different questions
first of all of course grief
recognizes the vaccination certificates
issued in russia
and anyone
who has been vaccinated
alternative ways as well like you can do
the
coronavirus testing uh 72 hours prior
entering the country
we are ready to accept tourists in
any number of tours including russian
tourists
as for the vaccine itself
since greece is a member of the european
union
then of course this decision depends on
the eu
and we will follow the guidelines the eu
guidelines in this respect
we do think
it's important to vaccinate and all
vaccines should be
accepted and there are no reasons not to
accept certain vaccines of course i
can't give you any
timeline because it just doesn't exist
my question is for the russian foreign
minister
how can you comment on the incident
that took place yesterday in minsk
when um the airplane was directed to the
minsk airport and one of the
passengers was detained and he has
already commented
and a lot of countries are concerned
about what happened
but what is the basis
for this detention and what how is
moscow going to react
a comment had been made regarding that
by the kremlin already we believe that
this situation
should not be looked at in a
hurry we need to have all the
information before we make any judgments
press secretary of the foreign ministry
of belarus
has made a detailed comment he said that
belarus would like to act transparently
in this manner and follow all
international
law procedures would like to guarantee
transparency when it comes to
accepting international experts i think
this is a reasonable approach
it was also emphasized that belarus is
ready to provide
all uh details or materials
that would uh confirm
that the aviation regulators and
authorities acted
in accordance with the international law
since you mentioned this belarusian
individual national
we know that a friend of his a
russian national also
is currently in minsk and we our
embassy there also already contacted her
and we uh already
made a statement that we would like to
establish
access to her i know
that there is a number of reports
that have to do with
similar uh cases in the past the most
notable of which is in 2013 when uh
because of u.s austria
diverted a plane carrying the bolivian
president
without any consequences
to them after that or maybe 2016 for
example
when a plane of the belarusian
airlines was downed forcefully
in libya because the ukrainian
authority were interested in
the national armenians so this national
was taken off the plane
and the plane just went on so
we emphasize this we need to be sober
when
reacting to events like this
again the belarusian authorities are
ready to provide all information
necessary
okay if there are no more questions then
the press conference is over thank you
thank you
you